Optimizarea clasică este un pas esențial în algoritmii cuantici clasici
precum variational quantum eigensolver sau machine learning cuantic.
Totuși, de multe ori se dovedește dificil să minimizezi
funcții complicate în spații de parametri de înaltă dimensiune.
Mă numesc Victoria Lipinska și în acest video vom explora
rutine de optimizare clasică pentru algoritmii cuantici clasici.
Problemele de optimizare nu sunt ușoare.
Pe măsură ce numărul de parametri crește, crește și numărul de combinații
posibile de valori, și anume exponențial.
La șah, de exemplu, există 64 de câmpuri
și fiecare jucător are 16 piese; după ce fiecare jucător mută o singură piesă,
există 400 de poziții diferite. După două mutări, 72.084 de poziții,
aproximativ 9 milioane după trei și aproximativ
280 de miliarde după patru mutări.
Dacă ajungem la doar 40 de mutări, numărul de poziții posibile
este estimat la aproximativ zece la puterea 120.
A juca un joc perfect ar presupune explorarea tuturor pozițiilor posibile
și această creștere enormă înseamnă că parcurgerea
tuturor pozițiilor individual este nerealizabilă.
Asta se poate rezolva împărțind problema în două sub-probleme mai mici.
În primul rând, trebuie să determinăm ce configurații ale tablei de șah
au șanse să apară în pașii următori ai jocului nostru.
Vom numi asta subspațiul nostru de interes.
Și în al doilea rând, dat fiind acel subspațiu, trebuie să determinăm ce mutare e cea mai bună.
Vom numi asta cea mai bună mutare.
În această analogie, căutarea inițială prin subspațiul de interes
este analogul algoritmului nostru de optimizare clasică.
Odată ce acel subspațiu de interes este cunoscut,
un algoritm cuantic este de obicei responsabil pentru găsirea celei mai bune mutări,
dat fiind acel subspațiu.
Să începem considerând doar un singur parametru,
theta, care parametrizează o funcție de cost pe care vrem să o optimizăm.
Dacă reprezentăm grafic funcția, să zicem că arată cam așa,
pe axa X avem valorile parametrului theta
și pe axa Y se află funcția de cost.
Ține minte că funcția de cost ar putea fi un cost financiar real
pe care vrem să-l minimizăm sau, cum e adesea cazul în variational quantum
eigensolver, ar putea fi o energie minimizată de natură.
Obiectivul nostru este să găsim theta-ul
care corespunde costului minim.
Pornim cu o valoare inițială a lui theta și în fiecare pas de optimizare
găsim un theta nou care reduce și mai mult costul.
Se pare că știm destul de ușor în ce direcție să mergem pe grafic dacă îl putem vedea.
Dar dificultatea în optimizare constă în faptul că de fapt nu știm.
Aflăm doar costul, adică o bucățică mică din întreaga imagine,
atunci când evaluăm funcția pe theta-ul selectat.
Acesta este modul general în care funcționează optimizarea.
Optimizatorul eșantionează parametrii theta și calculează costul.
Cum îți poți imagina, alegerea aleatoare a parametrului theta pentru a reconstitui
întreaga topologie a funcției nu este prea eficientă.
În schimb, ce fac optimizatoarele inteligente este să găsească
gradientul funcției la fiecare pas.
Astfel optimizatorul știe în ce direcție pe grafic
să meargă pentru a găsi costul minim.
Odată ce gradientul este zero, algoritmul se termină
și minimul este găsit.
Acest minim s-ar putea să nu fie minimul global.
Poate fi un minim local,
adică cea mai mică valoare a funcției de cost din vecinătate
dar nu pe întregul interval al lui theta.
În cazul unui singur parametru, asta e cu siguranță posibil.
Totuși, cu cât avem mai mulți parametri,
cu atât funcția devine mai complicată.
Deja în cazul a doi parametri avem o suprafață,
iar în cazul a patru nu mai putem nici măcar să o desenăm.
La fel ca în exemplul cu șahul, reproducerea tuturor posibilităților
devine rapid de nerezolvat.
Vedem că e greu să minimizezi
funcții complicate în spații de parametri de înaltă dimensiune.
Totuși, pentru a obține rezultate rezonabile, vrem ca rutinele de optimizare clasică
să fie atât rapide, cât și precise.
De asemenea, trebuie să fie robuste la zgomot,
care va avea un efect semnificativ în calculatoarele cuantice din viitorul apropiat.
Algoritmii de optimizare clasică pot fi împărțiți în linii mari
în două clase: metode de căutare directă și metode bazate pe gradient.
Metodele bazate pe gradient necesită informații despre gradientul
funcției în timpul procesului de optimizare.
Acesta poate fi calculat analitic
sau aproximat printr-un calcul de diferențe finite.
Metodele de căutare directă nu folosesc informații despre gradient
și utilizează alte strategii pentru a minimiza funcția de cost.
Unii dintre cei mai frecvent utilizați algoritmi de optimizare
în peisajul computației cuantice sunt următorii optimizatori.
COBYLA înseamnă optimizare cu constrângeri prin aproximare liniară
și este un algoritm de optimizare fără gradient.
SLSQP înseamnă programare secvențială cu cele mai mici pătrate,
un algoritm de optimizare bazat pe gradient.
SPSA folosește un vector de perturbație stochastic
pentru a calcula simultan un gradient aproximativ al funcției de cost.
Într-un mediu fără zgomot, optimizatori precum COBYLA
și SLSQP s-au dovedit a converge mai repede decât SPSA.
Optimizatorii clasici au propriii lor parametri
pe care îi poți specifica pentru cazuri particulare, de exemplu, pasul.
Aceștia pot fi găsiți de obicei în documentația aferentă
optimizatorului specific.
Vă încurajez să consultați lista de referințe de mai jos pentru o comparație
a celor mai actuali optimizatori clasici.
Să explorăm încă un fenomen legat
de optimizarea clasică a circuit-urilor cuantice parametrizate.
Așa cum am văzut, un gradient care dispare al funcției de cost poate indica
că optimizatorul a ajuns pe un platou fără trăsături interesante, un așa-numit
„barren plateau".
Un barren plateau poate fi rezultatul mai multor factori.
Gradientul funcției de cost corespunzătoare unui circuit cuantic
cu parametri inițializați aleatoriu
scade exponențial la zero odată cu numărul de qubits.
Asta deoarece spațiul cuantic explorat de optimizator
devine exponențial de mare pe măsură ce numărul de qubits crește.
Modalitățile de a aborda această problemă includ reducerea numărului de parametri
și deci a dimensiunii spațiului subiacent.
Un alt mod de a înțelege originea problemei barren plateau
ar putea fi natura agnostică față de problemă a circuit-ului parametrizat
confruntat cu un spațiu de parametri exponențial de mare.
Proiectarea unui circuit adaptat problemei avute în vedere
ar putea fi o soluție bună.
Pe lângă spațiul exponențial de parametri care generează barren plateaus,
alte fenomene fizice le pot genera și ele:
zgomotul și decoerența prezente în experimentele de computație cuantică,
expresibilitatea generală a circuit-ului parametrizat,
sau nelocalitatea și gradul de entanglement al funcției de cost modelate.
Rămâne un domeniu activ de cercetare abordarea acestor provocări.
Acum că am trecut în revistă componentele principale ale VQE,
vom rezuma algoritmul în videoclipul următor.